- [Announcer] This program
is a presentation of UCTV
for educational and
non-commercial use only.
(solemn music)
- Now, yesterday you heard
a detailed introduction
about her background
and all the awards she's won
so there's no reason for me to reiterate
how she just won the
$100,000 Gairdner Award
or the Selman Waksman Award
from the National Academy of Science
or that she's been the
first female director
of the Beckman Center and she's done
all these amazing things.
So the first thing that
came to mind is why me?
Why do I get to introduce Lucy Shapiro?
So I thought about it and I thought well,
we both went to Brooklyn College,
we both escaped from New York
and we were both work on
developmental bacteria
that don't cause any disease
and most people haven't heard of,
until recently.
So why caulobacter?
Well, caulobacter has
an interesting history.
It really came into
prominence when Roger Stanier
and Jeanne Poindexter isolated it,
they were looking for
organisms that would grow
in the distilled water of
the Life Science Building
and sure enough, they isolated
caulobacter crescentus
because it grows in very
dilute environments.
Of course, a little bit while later,
Mike Doudoroff told me they
found a dead rat in it still,
so possibly there was some
organic material there as well.
Anyway, after Stanier
and Jeanne Poindexter worked out
the life cycle of this
very interesting organism
and realized that it has two forms;
it forms a stem cell
like a stalk cell
that puts out Swarmer cells
and this was a very interesting model
for studying cell differentiation.
Dr. Shapiro realized the
tremendous power of this system
and she almost single-handedly developed
this field from just kind of
a gee whiz type phenomenology
of bacteriology into a
detailed model system
for studying the cell cycle.
So she's accomplished quite a bit.
She has over 250 papers, she's mentored
over 31 PhD students, 50 postdocs
and her recent graduates
have established themselves
in major universities and
actually, throughout the world.
So it's really a credit to her
that she's accomplished all this.
And so I'm very pleased to
introduce Professor Lucy Shapiro
to give her lecture on caulobacter.
(audience applause)
- Thank you, it's a
pleasure being here today.
I might add to the introduction
that David Zusman gave you
about where caulobacter grows.
When I was at Albert
Einstein College of Medicine
in The Bronx, we isolated one
of the first bacteriophages
that infects caulobacter
in The Bronx tap water
and it's the largest phage ever isolated.
So whether there are dead
rats in the drinking water
in The Bronx or not, I don't know
but certainly caulobacter
can be found everywhere
and it is probably one of the
most ubiquitous bugs on earth.
We have used this bug
as a way of carrying out, in
essence, systems engineering
on a living entity.
What I show here is the
cell cycle of caulobacter
and why we're interested in it.
As you can see, every
division is asymmetric.
You start off with a cell that can swim,
it's called a swarmer cell,
it has a flagellum at one pole
and there are pili at this pole as well.
This is the chromosome.
This cell is not able to
initiate DNA replication
and it's present and swims
around for about a third
of the cell cycle, independent
of the generation time
and independent of the nutrients.
Once this swarmer cell
differentiates into a stalk cell
by ejecting the flagellum and
building a stalk in this place
and as Jeff Skurka showed,
sucking these pili back in,
then you can initiate
DNA replication shown
by this theta structure.
Replication goes on during this S phase.
Cell division happens
here but you start making
the components of the cell
division machine quite early.
Flagella biogenesis occurs in a hierarchy
of about 42 genes and then is assembled
at one side of the cell and nowhere else.
Once the chromosome has
completed its replication
then an enzyme that methylates
the DNA gets turned on
and this is important because
I'm gonna come back to this.
So when the cell divides,
you have two fully methylated chromosomes
and when you initiate replication
and the replication fork
travels around the chromosome,
you get two copies that are hemimethylated
and then you don't, that would be here,
this is a fully methylated,
you initiate replication
and you get two copies
that are hemimethylated.
The reason why it happens just here
is that the cell, as I'll show
you at the end of this talk,
uses the methylation
state of the chromosome
to integrate multiple regulatory events.
And pili biogenesis, of course,
happens between here and
here in the cell cycle.
Each one of these boxes represents
what I call a functional module.
In other words, there are multiple genes
within each one of these boxes
that have to carry out their function.
Each module gets turned
on at a specific time
in the cell cycle and there
are four master regulators
that control 200 cell
cycle regulated genes.
Each group within this 200,
sits in one of these boxes.
So now turning to understand
how this might be,
not how you might get regulators
to turn these various things on
and how many levels of
control allow you to do this
and most importantly,
how are these regulatory
events coordinated?
So back in the year 2000,
a then graduate student
in the lab, Mike Laub,
did the first cell cycle
microarray of a bacterial cell.
We had just gotten the sequence from TIGR
and what he did was
synchronize the cell cycle
which is probably one of the
best things about caulobacter,
you can actually synchronize these cells
and starting with a swarmer
cell every 15 minutes,
he took a sample, got the
RNA and then did microarrays
and in yellow, it shows
genes that are turned on,
blue, genes that are turned off
and there is a hardwired
pattern during the cell cycle
of a consistent set of genes
that are turn on and off
as you move through the cell cycle.
An example is very the
DnaA gene which is required
for the initiation of DNA replication.
And that's turned on in
preparation for turning on
the replication of the chromosome.
Another example is the
hierarchy of flagellar genes
that are turned on just when needed
to build the flagellum at this pole.
And here is that DNA methyltransferase
that's turned on at the
end of the cell cycle
to remethylate the chromosome.
And I could fill this in
with many, many, many genes.
We know almost all of them at this point
and so this is turning on a gene,
not in response to glucose
or not in response to lactose
but rather, a hardwired
pattern of gene expression
as you move through the cell cycle.
What could be involved in this?
Well, bacteria and caulobacter
as well, generally use
the two-component signal
transduction paradigm.
Most of the initial work
revealing how these things
have been done was done by Sydney Kustu,
here at at Berkeley and the paradigm
is that there is a histidine kinase
which can have a part of
its protein sticking out
into the periplasmic space
or it can be inside.
Generally a dimer, and some signal,
either inside or outside
causes autophosphorylation
of the histidine and then CtrA
is phosphorylated on an aspartate.
In this case, this is the
global regulator in caulobacter
and here we have a
response regulator attached
to a DNA binding domain which
does not have to be the case.
In this case, it is true and it acts as
a transcriptional regulator.
Kim Quon, a graduate student
in the lab identified CtrA
and then Christine Jacobs, when she was
a postdoc in the lab,
identified the kinase that's involved
in this phosphorylation reaction.
There has since been shown to
be another protein in between
but I'm not gonna go into that.
This CtrA protein was very surprising.
It was found, initially,
because it controlled flagella biogenesis
but it was very perplexing
because it was also
an essential gene and the flagellum
is not essential for viability.
And then it turned out, I had
different people in the lab,
working on different functional modules
and to our astonishment,
we found that this one,
regulatory protein controlled the onset
of flagella biogenesis, pili biogenesis,
turned on the the DNA
methyltransferase gene,
turned on the genes for
the chemotaxis machinery
as well as cell division genes.
One curious thing about
this response regulator,
is it's not only a transcription factor
but when it's present in the cell,
it sits on the origin of
replication and silences it.
So there is a protein that
both is a transcription factor
and a silencer of the
initiation of DNA replication.
This protein does not
control stalk biogenesis,
DNA replication or chromosome segregation
but as you can see here,
where I've colored in
where CtrA is, CtrA is in a swarmer cell,
where it's sitting on
the origin of replication
and silencing it, then, in order
to turn on DNA replication,
this thing has to be
cleared out of the cell.
Then you stop the proteolysis of CtrA,
it again now accumulates,
turns on functional things
and then there is a closure
of the inner membrane
of this pre-divisional cell
creating two compartments.
This compartment has the CtrA in it
and you're silencing the origin.
This compartment, again,
clear CtrA out of the cell
by proteolysis so you can
initiate DNA replication;
therefore, each progeny of
a division is asymmetric,
you get two different cells.
Not only do they look
different because this guy
can swim away and this guy's got a stalk
but this one cannot
initiate DNA replication
and this one always does.
Clearly, that's this one.
So now, I showed that CtrA is present,
gets cleared away, it comes back,
gets cleared away here asymmetrically.
What about this kinase?
Here's the intermediary protein.
And this was an experiment
that Christine did.
She first showed
that this kinase was present
throughout the cell cycle
by Western blots but it seemed
to be only functioning sometimes
so what she did was label
it with a GFP derivative
and made the surprising observation
that this protein is localized
to the pole of the cell
and Antonio Iniesta and Nathan Hilson
have recently shown that if
this thing isn't localized
to the pole of the cell, it can't function
and it is at these times in the cell cycle
that it is involved in phosphoryl transfer
to the CtrA protein and activating it.
So again, by the time
Christine showed this,
Janine Matic in the lab had already shown
that the chemoreceptors are
localized at the cell pole
so we knew that polar
localization of proteins,
in fact, happened so now we
were faced with the question,
how do you go about using the
three-dimensional organization
of the cell as a regulatory phenomenon?
How do you incorporate that
into transcriptional circuitry,
into proteolysis, into the
multiple layers of control?
One of the critical events
which I'm sure you realize
at this point is getting rid of CtrA here
and it has to be absolutely specific
and it has to be controlled.
So this is now another
surprising observation.
The ClpXP protease, which has six subunits
of the chaperone ClpX and 14 subunits
of the protease ClpP, it's
like a little Waring blender,
CtrA binds to a factor RcdA,
which then brings it
into the Waring blender and chews it up
but the surprise was that
this protease complex,
localizes to the pole of the cell.
And then the CtrA and
RcdA, in other words,
the substrate, comes down to the protease,
CtrA is chewed up and then surprisingly,
it goes away from this
pole but then assembles
at the cell division
plane, goes away from that
and then reassembles only at this pole
so that you chew CtrA
up here but not here.
So this is just an example,
a cute little movie that
was made by Antonio Iniesta
and his work is really a summary
of the work of Antonio
Iniesta, Patrick McGrath
and Kathleen Ryan and as you can see,
it goes to the pole and
the substrate comes in
and it's chewed up.
This ClpXP protein is a single
domain response regulator
that, in fact, is required to, excuse me,
the CpdR, single domain response regulator
is the factor that is
required to bring ClpXP
to the cell pole.
So now, the critical question is
how is this integrated
with the passage through
the cell cycle and the role
of the two components signal
transduction proteins?
So this CpdR protein which I
introduced to you once before
as a single domain response regulator
can exist in the phosphorylated state
or the unphosphorylated state.
When it's in the unphosphorylated
state, we call it active
because it's in the unphosphorylated state
that it allows the protease
complex to go to the cell pole.
What's amazing is that this kinase
that I showed you a moment ago
as the kinase that activates
CtrA is the same kinase
that keeps this CpdR protein
in the phosphorylated state.
So in a very robust way, the same kinase
that activates CtrA
prevents its degradation
by keeping this thing in
the phosphorylated state.
Now, when we have CpdR in
the unphosphorylated state,
it localizes the protease, CtrA and RcdA
then go to the protease and get degraded.
Now let's put it together
with the localization
of this kinase.
So here we are in the swarmer cell
and in the swarmer cell, CpdR exists
in the phosphorylated state,
therefore the protease
is not localized, then
you have the localization of the protease
and it substrates here, it's degraded
and then you get the
localization of this kinase
to this pole and it's now active.
So what happens when
this kinase is active?
CpdR accumulates in the
phosphorylated state,
those were all the yellow dots
then this begins to form two
compartments with the
kinase trapped up here
and because of that triggered
by cytoplasmic compartmentalization,
you then degrade CtrA
because the protease via CpdR
is localized to that cell pole.
So in fact, there is a correlation
between multiple
three-dimensional observations.
Number one, you have to
localize the protease itself
to a specific place.
Number two, when you
form two compartments,
you trap the protease in one
compartment and not the other
and you are trapping the kinase
that makes sure that this guy is not able
to localize the protease but this one is.
So there is now a connection
between localized proteolysis
and the phosphosignaling cascade.
This thing then chews up CtrA
and it can initiate DNA replication.
So what I've shown you
is that CtrA is cycling
through the cell cycle but
we predict that there has
to be at least another
regulator that happens
when CtrA isn't around because we know
that multiple proteins are made
at all these different times
in the cell cycle.
So the second regulatory
protein, GcrA shown here in blue,
well which was found by Holtzendorff
is present when the when
CtrA is not present.
And CtrA, as I showed
you, controls 95 genes,
that's directly controls 95 genes
by doing chip analysis.
And GcrA controls the expression
of approximately 50 genes
and these 50 genes are
involved in DNA replication
and chromosome segregation.
So swarmer cell has it then
it goes away by proteolysis,
GcrA builds up, the early
pre-divisional cell one
is going away and the other is building up
so you have CtrA here
then you have the differential expression,
GcrA because here it can't be made,
here you clear out CtrA
and GcrA can be made
so now when the cell divides,
the asymmetry is not just morphological;
this can swim, this has a stalk,
this has CtrA, this has GcrA.
And these are major transcription factors
that are controlling different genes.
So if we look now at a circuitry,
a regulatory genetic pathway, that CtrA,
activated CtrA phosphate controls
and its phosphorylation is a complicated
phosphokinase pathway.
This CtrA phosphate controls
all of these modules
as I showed you initially.
Here is CtrA phosphate
sitting at five sites
on the origin of DNA
replication and silencing it.
Clearly, the degratory
pathway is critical.
Now, we can put on top of this
the 50 cell cycle regulated
genes that GcrA controls,
controlling multiple
genes that are involved
in replication of the
chromosome and in segregation
as well as the localization
of kinases at the cell pole.
So how does GcrA and CtraA
deal with one another?
So (coughs) excuse me.
It forms a regulatory cycle.
When CtrA is present,
it sits on the GcrA
promoter and silences it.
It also acts and excuse me,
and when you get rid of CtrA
then you can turn on GcrA.
When GcrA is turned on and does its thing,
it then turns on the P1 promoter of CtrA.
You make some CtrA, it's activated,
it shuts off GcrA, it
shuts off its P1 promoter
and turns on the very active P2 promoter.
So what we have here is
an oscillating circuit
that has GcrA and CtrA doing their things
at different times in the cell cycle.
What was particularly surprising
was that this oscillation
is linked to DNA replication
and I'm gonna come back to this again
but in front of the P1 promoter
is a DNA methylation site
and the transcription of
this gene is dependent
on this being in the hemimethylated state.
Now the GcrA gene, which we
know is turned off by CtrA,
what turns it on and that
turns out to be DnaA,
a protein that has been
known in bacterial,
almost all bacterial
cells, seemingly forever.
DnaA is a protein that's
required for the initiation
of bacterial DNA replication,
it does so by interacting
with the single origin
of replication, allowing it to open up
and form the replisome.
Not too long ago, a couple of years ago,
both in Alan Grossman's lab
studying bacillus subtilis
and in our own lab, Allison Hottes
and Justine Collier showed that DnaA
is a transcription factor and
it's a transcription factor
for approximately 50 genes that are needed
right at that time in the cell cycle.
So just like CtrA does double duty
as a repressor or silencer
of the origin of replication
and a transcription factor,
then DnaA does double duty
as an activator of DNA replication
and as well as a transcription factor.
So now that we knew that, somehow,
this cycle is hooked up
to the replication of the chromosome,
it was a puzzle, how could this be?
How could all these parts be integrated?
How does the cell know
when to do X or Y or Z?
How are the modules ordered?
So we then decided and that is
including Martin Thanbichler
and Patrick Viollier and Patrick McGrath,
we looked at the caulobacter cell
and it was pretty much assumed
that the bacterial chromosome
was a bowl of spaghetti,
sitting inside of the cell
with no nuclear membrane
and there were indications
that the cell at least knew
where the origin was and
where the terminus was.
And that's shown here; the
origin sat at this pole
of the cell where the flagellum was
and the terminus sat at the other pole.
So what we wanted to ask
is where are the rest
of the genes in the
cell, all the other loci,
is it really just a random mess?
And so using a well-known
technique at that point,
in which you put in a whole
array of DNA binding proteins
to a specific place on the chromosome,
here we're putting in tetO sequences
and then we had a plasmid driving tetR
fused to YFP and if we
turned on that plasmid,
we were able then to attach this tag,
fluorescently tagged binding protein
to a side in the chromosome
and that would light up a
specific place in the cell.
We also, in all the experiments we did
with this kind of technique, we did FISH
so that we didn't have to
just depend on multiple pieces
of DNA stuck into the chromosome
and we confirmed it
all with FISH analysis.
And so doing this, what we
found is that the chromosome
is really amazingly ordered.
What I'm showing you here is a cartoon,
it does not mean that this is the order.
All we do know is that
where a genetic loci exists
on the chromosome reflects
where it sits in the cell
so that loci closer to the origin
or sit down here, further
away, they move up the gradient
so that there is a specific place
and it has a radius of attachment
but it's within an area
for individual loci in the cell.
So here we have the origin of replication.
When you get rid of CtrA
and you're no longer silencing the origin
then you build the replisome
and that's shown here in green,
on this region then what you find
is that as soon as you
initiate DNA replication,
the newly duplicated origin
can be seen to harpoon across the cell
and establish itself at the other pole.
And here you have the light
blue new chromosome going up
and the old stuff getting smaller
and you keep moving it apart.
And what I show down
here is actually a movie
of the tagged origin of replication
which is shown here being duplicated
and harpooning across the cell.
To us, this was very exciting.
It is not as showy as
looking at eukaryotic cells
but this rather blew my
mind when it happened,
we can actually see a
locus move across the cell
and calculate its speed of movement.
Now a graduate student
in the lab, Esteban Tore
has recently shown that
the thing that first moves
across the cell is not the
caulobacter origin of replication
but a sequence not far away from it,
called the parS sequence
and in a very elegant
series of experiments,
Esteban showed that it
is this parS sequence
that sits away from the
origin of replication
that moves first across
the cell and that parS
is the centromeric
sequence that is the site
of force generation that
drives chromosome segregation
and by making a series of inversions,
he was able to show that
no matter where you put
this parS sequence,
that's what moved first
and you had to replicate through it
in order to get the movement.
So now what I show here is a overview
of what I've been telling you.
Here now is the swarmer cell.
Now, I'm showing this little red dot
or origin as parS, terminus is here,
you clear CtrA out of the
cell, the replisome forms.
What I've done here is
indicated a genetic locus,
some generic genetic locus in gold
and what happens here is
you have parA driven segregation of parS.
ParA is an ATPase that
assembles into a polymer
and the newly replicated parS sequence
then moves across the entire cell
and when it reaches the other pole,
it's anchored at that pole
by a polymeric network
of a protein called popC,
this was found in our lab
by a Grant Bowman, at the same time
as we published this in
cell, Christine Jacobs Wagner
also found popC in her lab.
So the work is definitely corroborated,
two labs have it and
it's an amazing protein
because it's a 19 kilodalton protein
that forms a very large
polymeric complex at that pole
and is essential for grabbing
this centromeric sequence
and holding it there at that pole.
If you don't have popC,
the chromosome keeps trying
to go to that pole but it goes there
and draws back, goes there and draws back.
You have to grab it and keep it there
but now coming back to the duplication
of the chromosome, once the replisome
moves through this locus, we
find that it is segregated
to the mirror image position
of the incipient daughter cell.
So that in fact, we have
segregation occurring
while you're replicating the chromosome
and this region of the chromosome knows
how to go to the right place then
you finish DNA replication,
the replisome disassembles
and you get two cells
that are mirror images of one another.
This cell now cannot initiate replication.
This cell, you get rid of CtrA
so you can build the
replisome and start again.
So now that we know
that there are very logical progression
of DNA replication occurring,
how can we integrate
multiple cell cycle events
with this replication of the chromosome?
So I'm gonna tell you two short stories;
one is the spatial regulation
of division site placement
which is dependent on the positioning
of that centromeric sequencer.
And the other is DNA methylation control
of the actual cell cycle regulators.
So first, the division site placement.
This, again, is the work
of Martin Thanbichler
and Martin identified
a protein called MipZ
which is an ATPase, a ParA like ATPase
that's absolutely essential
for placing the FtsZ gene
in the middle of this FtsZ ring
in the middle of the cell.
Sure, we do know that when
cell division happens,
you have asymmetry in
a smaller swarmer cell
and a larger stalk cell
but that's because once the division ring
is laid down mid-cell,
this portion of the cell
does not grow as fast as
that portion of the cell.
Furthermore, we know
that this shown in blue
is the origin centromere
region and MipZ colocalizes
with that origin region.
So now here is, which I
should change this to ParS
at this point or the centromere
and that is decorated by the ParB factor
and ParB then binds directly to MipZ,
this was shown by
surface plasmon resonance
but it doesn't just have
a very orderly attachment.
It seems to form some sort
of gradient in the cell
so if we look at MipZ EYFP,
you see it at its highest
concentration at the pole
but then it becomes less
and less as you move
towards the center whereas EGFP ParB
is very tightly bound at the pole
and this gradient of MipZ concentration
which is highest at the origin regions
and lowest at mid cell, is what
in fact gives the function,
gives the function to
the MipZ-ParB complex.
So how does it do this?
Well, Martin showed that if
you purify the FtsZ protein,
FtsZ is a tubulin that has to assemble
into these long polymers.
If you add purified MipZ to purified FtsZ,
you get these short
non-functional curlicues
and then he went on and showed that MipZ,
in fact, stimulates the GTPase activity
of FtsZ, preventing it from assembling.
So therefore, we knew that
we could put together a model
of this cell, in which
here's the centromere
or origin sequence,
decorated with the ParB
segregation factor,
MipZ is on it.
At the other pole of the
cell and this is a new pole
that just resulted from a cell division.
So you have a pool of the FtsZ protein
or tubulin sitting here
and as you now duplicate
this region of the chromosome,
you redecorate it immediately
with ParB and MipZ and as
it moves across the cell
and sees, hits the FtsZ, the FtsZ moves
to the region of lowest
concentration of MipZ
and that's where it assembles.
And I can actually show you this.
So what I'm showing you
here are two cells in red.
I show the ParB bow to the
origin region and in green,
is the pool of FtsZ at this pole.
Here's just a second cell,
we initiate DNA replication
and as it moves across the cell,
it hits the FtsZ and
FtsZ assembles mid-cell.
And Martin has elegant movies,
where he can chase the
FtsZ around the cell
so that wherever MipZ
is, FtsZ can polymerize.
So in fact, what Martin has shown,
that this complex
represents a novel system
that coordinates chromosome
origin segregation
with the initiation of cell division
and furthermore, it ensures
the proper localization
of the division plane to mid-cell,
the region of lowest concentration
of the MipZ inhibitor.
Now, turning to the second story
that is involved closely
with the coincidence
of DNA replication and segregation,
the DNA methylation control
of the cell cycle master regulators,
we knew and I've been showing you
that this is a Western blot
of when each of these proteins
is present in the cell,
going through the cell cycle
and we knew that GcrA is turned on here.
GcrA turns on CtrA.
CtrA turns on the DNA methyltransferase
and DnaA, which starts the whole thing
because DnaA turns on GcrA, et cetera,
what turns on DnaA and
how do you, in fact,
make this a cycle?
So what Justine Callier
found is that it depends
on the methylation state
of the promoter region.
So let me see if I can make this clear.
Here is a caulobacter chromosome,
here is the origin of
replication, I flipped it over.
Here is the terminus.
This is where the DnaA gene sits.
This is where the CtrA gene sets.
In bacteria and in caulobacter,
replication is bi-directional
and when you begin this and now we're
in the swarmer cell, cell is just divided.
The chromosome is in the
fully methylated state,
a specific sequence, GANTCC is methylated
on Watson and Crick, one way to put that.
There is a DNA methylation
site within the DnaA promoter
and this is in a fully methylated state
so the DnaA gene is transcribed.
However, CtrA is also in
a fully methylated state
and it's not transcribed because this guy
can only be transcribed from
a hemimethylated promoter.
Now as the replication
initiates and moves through,
first the DnaA gene, you
get two copies of the gene
that are now both in the
hemimethylated state.
Just remember I told
you, you don't turn on
that DNA methylating enzyme
till the end of the cell cycle.
So this is now hemimethylated,
you turn off the transcription of DnaA,
the replication fork on this side
hasn't yet hit CtrA so this
guy is not transcribed either.
However, once the replication fork travels
through the CtrA gene, creating
two hemimethylated copies,
then you turn on the transcription
of that P1 promoter of CtrA.
Therefore, the passage of
the replication fork itself
controls methylation state and thereby,
controlling the timing of
activation of the promoters
of these two genes.
Now I wanna remind you that each protein
is controlled at multiple levels.
It's controlled by turning
on its transcription.
It's controlled by
proteolysis at the right time
of the cell cycle, it's
controlled by positioning
and it's controlled by activation.
CtrA has to be activated.
DnaA has to be activated
so there are multiple levels of control.
We found that if we moved DnaA far away
from its normal site so the timing
of its transcriptional control is changed,
the cell is still alive
but it's severely impaired.
If you make a mixed
population of a wild-type cell
and a cell in which this
gene is moved down here,
the cell in which this is
moved is gonna disappear
within a generation, it's gone
and the same thing is true
of moving the CtrA gene and curiously,
moving the CtraA gene,
the cells seem confused,
they're of all different sizes.
And we don't really know what causes this
but they're not dead so what
we're looking at is robustness.
If we put back into this circuit
everything I've told you,
this would be the epigenetic control
and that's not really the correct phrase.
What this is is differential
methylation of these genes.
So DnaA which is transcribed
from a fully methylated promoter controls,
here it was 40 genes, I
think it's up to 50 now.
DnaA then turns on GcrA which
controls about 50 genes.
GcrA turns on the P1 promoter of CtrA.
I told you about this oscillating circuit.
CtrA controls about 95 genes
and inhibits DNA replication
and it also turns on this
DNA methyltransferase.
Interestingly, there are
two methylation sites
within the plus one region of CcrM
and as soon as these are methylated,
you turn off the expression of CcrM.
So this DNA methyltransferase
is like a shot of the
DNA methyltransferase.
It methylates up 1400 GANTC
sites around the chromosome
and then is cleared out of the cell
very rapidly by proteolysis.
Then while it's rapidly turning
on a whole bunch of genes,
it methylates up the DnaA gene
and you can start the
cell cycle all over again.
So in fact, given all of
these coordinated events
that occur to give you
a logical progression
of the cell cycle, we can
make some conclusions.
One, we believe that there's
a small number of regulated,
of master regulators that are controlled
both temporally and spatially
and they oscillate
throughout the cell cycle.
The control system is
hierarchically organized,
there's stuff at the
top then turns on these,
turns on these.
A beautiful example of that
is the flagella hierarchy,
functions are turned on as
modules just in time when needed
and the synchronization of
this whole cell cycle engine
is linked to multiple other events,
for example, I showed you that
the reliable cell cycle functions,
the order is linked to
chromosome replication
and is also linked to the
phosphosignaling pathway,
which is linked to the
correct time of proteolysis
during the cell cycle so
you can get rid of things
when you have to get rid of them.
And most importantly, the
three-dimensional organization
of the cell matters.
The dynamic spatial positioning
of these regulatory proteins
is essential to their function.
Their position of the regulatory genes
on the chromosome can be essential.
And compartmentalization
triggers cell differentiation
so we have a paradigm
here where it's not enough
to study the transcriptional
regulatory network.
That is just a layer of
multiple layers of control
and if you want to model
a regulatory pathway,
simply looking at a
transcriptional network
can be very misleading.
Overall regulatory wiring
diagram, of course,
is selected for robustness and in fact,
this DNA methylation regulation
is something that
contributes to the fitness
of the organism not life and death.
So in fact, what I've
shown you is that there's
a forward-biased circuitry
that drives cell cycle progression
and the progression through the cell cycle
is pasted in a ratchet like fashion
so that you have gates moving forward
and opening, allow you to go
from one state to another.
And what I've shown here is
just some of these gates,
coming back to the
first slide I showed you
when I started this talk.
So here is the cell cycle, here
are the functional modules.
One of the gates is that
replication initiation
is triggered by proteolysis of CtrA.
It's clearly not the only thing
but it's one of the licensing events.
Then DNA origin segregation
to the opposite pole triggers
the cell division machine, another gate,
always moving forward.
Gate three, the
compartmentalization at this point
in the cell cycle, triggers
daughter cell asymmetry
by trapping different regulators
at the two different poles of the cell.
So in fact, what I've shown you is that
if you take a logical
approach to the cell cycle,
trying to understand how
multiple events happen
at specific times and are dependent
on all the events that happen before it,
you get the forward progression
throughout the cell cycle
and we have a systematic explanation
of cell cycle expression in a living cel.
And what I have here is I'd like to thank
the extraordinary group of
graduate students and postdocs
who have worked on this,
not only currently,
including Antonio Iniesta and Grant Bowman
and Esteban Tore but the large group
of people who now all run their own labs
and are fierce and incredibly
wonderful competitors,
running their own caulobacter lab
and I also want to mention that our lab
is closely integrated with
the lab run by Harley McAdams.
Harley McAdams is a physicist
who has become interested
and learned the language or
genetics and biochemistry
and in his lab, his students
are all getting their PhDs
in computer science, EE or physics
and what we've done is we've
integrated our two labs
so that we have physicists
sitting next to geneticists
and electrical engineers
sitting next to biochemists
and instead of a biologist saying,
"Look, we have this problem.
"Mr. Physicist, solve this for us,"
we designed the experiments together
and we understand what we
need to ask the questions
and how we can interpret the results.
Sure these guys must write algorithms
and they help us figure
out how to build beautiful
technologically advanced equipment
but that's not the point.
We learn each other's language
and we learn to think in different ways.
So I would like to sort of give a plug
for interdisciplinary work.
I work closely with Harley.
Not everybody can work quite
as closely as he and I do,
since he's my husband.
But we do know how to talk to each other
and after all these
years, we still get along
and so I really recommend integrated labs.
I think they're wonderful.
And with that, I'd like to
thank you all very much.
(audience applause)
- I'd like to thank Professor Shapiro
for the amazing seminar
and it just shows you
that the caulobacter has come a long way
and is now a household word. (chuckles)
So Professor Shapiro is
going to entertain questions
and we'll do that up here.
- [Announcer] Yes, please
come up to the microphone,
thank you.
- [Man] So the force that
drives one ori to the next
after you get the--
- [Both] Initiation.
- [Man] Presumably, you asked me to think
about it yesterday.
Just hearing your seminar, it seems to me
that just the replication fork itself
might be enough to move--
- Yeah, but it's not.
- How can you eliminate--
- If you have a mutation
in parA that prevents
it from hydrolyzing ATP,
everything stops.
- [Man] But that says that it's necessary
but it might not be sufficient.
So part of the eg--
- Okay!
Okay, I give you that,
they could contribute
and Ling Xio suggested that
the force of replication per
se could contribute to it
but clearly, it's not.
- But there's not
a filament that runs--
- Oh, yes there is.
ParA polymerizes.
- [Man] I see, so you
think that maybe it moves--
- We've shown polymerization
of parA both in vivo
and in vitro and Ethan Gauner
has done the in vitro work
of the caulobacter parA and
yes, it is a polymer. (chuckles)
- [Man] One other, one other.
There is a lot going on at the ori
at different times.
- Yeah!
- The vicinity, so
presumably, the MipZ complex
that spreads comes on
after the initiation event,
that it doesn't--
- Yes, it comes on it.
- [Man] So the replication
fork doesn't move through it?
- No, no, no, it's decorated.
No, it's a very complicated
business going on it that's,
I use the word centromere,
what I'm doing is referring
to a sequence that is the
site of force generation.
Clearly, we have to
define all the proteins
that are coming on and
off that particular site
as this event is occurring.
- [Lady] Do you know something about
how widely distributed
in evolutionary history
this particular modular architecture is?
- Well, this is present
in, whenever you look
at an Alphaproteobacteria,
this whole system
is in there and what's interesting
is that, for example, a whole
CtraA regulation is there
but the output varies with
respect to the ecological niche
of the particular Alphaproteobacteria.
So that in brucella which infects people,
it turned on a different
set of genes ultimately
than are turned on in caulobacter.
In some Alphaproteobacteria,
CtrA is essential,
as in caulobacter and others, it's not
but in all instances,
it's controlling genes
that allow it to live and
survive in its environment.
- [Lady] So it is a master regulatory gene
in all of them--
- But it does
different things.
- But it's not necessarily,
controlling the same set of
down stretch right genes.
All right, thanks.
- [Man] You mind if I
put you on the spot Lucy?
- Oh well, please, feel free.
- [Man] I'm just curious,
since you do collaborate
with physicists, what
biological insight did
you have as a consequence
of a collaboration
with a physicist that
you wouldn't have had?
- There are a number of
ways of answering that.
I think the best example
is that when we were first contemplating
what the organization
of that genome was like
and we knew that the
origin was at one pole
and we knew that the terminus
was at the other pole
and what happened in between,
we knew that we could tag individual loci
but the question was,
alright, what do we do,
like lock up 20 graduate students
in a dark room for 10 years?
That didn't seem very logical
and so working with some
of our engineers and physicists,
they designed not only the
computer-driven microscope,
fluorescent scope, but they
designed the algorithms
that let the computer
analyze 50,000 images
of 114 different tagged loci
and yes, individual genes and
their position in the cell
had been visualized in E.
coli and in bacillus subtilis
but a few.
Now we're up to, I don't know, about 150.
So the whole question
was how general is this?
And we were able to answer
a very important question
because immediately, when
we first started talking
about this, my druthers was well,
you initiate replication,
you keep replicating
and then you start moving
or maybe you move the origin
and the rest comes after
it's all duplicated
and the physicists and
engineers said, "Wait a minute,
"that makes no sense.
"What you wanna do is you
wanna do it at the same time
"and let's see if the cell dies."
Hypothesis-driven research
as opposed to
non-hypothesis-driven research
and so that's one example
but there are many others.
- [Lady] So you talked about
this gates-driven architecture,
so certain events have to happen
for other events to happen
but then you also talked about
the process depending on time
and so I was interested if
there's also a master timer,
if you think, so both
time and the conditions
for the gates to happen have to be true
but can you slow things down?
- You can slow things down
by growing them on media
that they're not very happy
on, on a carbon source
that takes a lot to use
so you can slow down
the generation time but you
get exactly the same pathway.
And another timer, of course,
is the movement of the replication fork
because that's when you
get things turned on
and that lets you continue
at least at that level
but there are not only control mechanisms
of transcription, there are all those
other layered control mechanisms
that contribute to the
timing that are connected
with the morphology of
the cell and the time
when you get compartmentalization.
So I guess what I'm trying to say,
is that it's a layered and
complicated gate opening
as you move through to give you timing.
- [Lady] So I wanted to ask you,
it is very obvious that the
localization of the termini
and the origin at the two opposite poles
is very important for all this story
but you showed that the whole chromosome
is very localized and different,
what do you think the role of that,
where does that become important?
- Let me try to explain a bit
about what might be happening here.
The question is are there
many loci on the genome
that attach to the membrane
the way centromere does to the pole?
Is there another one or two or none?
And one possibility is once you harpoon
the duplicated origin to the other pole,
make-believe that the
replicating chromosome
is like a rope and you're standing
at the top of a swimming pool
and you're coiling the
newly replicated chromosome
down into the swimming pool
in the most logical
energy-saving confirmation.
And you're just wrapping it down
and packing it down into the cell
as though you're filling a phage head
and so it's not that
it's grabbing on to sites
and it's all specific but
rather, it's just physics,
just the most logical way
of packing into the cell.
This is a hypothesis, we
don't know whether it's true.
There might be sites, other sites
that are grabbing on to things in the cell
but we don't know that.
Esteban is sitting here now actually
is doing experiments to answer that.
So hopefully the next time I come back,
I can answer that question.
- [Man] I think you answered
my question towards the end
because you said the something
about the methyl transferase
added to the robustness of the system
but it wasn't required.
So I assume by that a deletion
of the methyl transferase is not lethal?
- It's lethal.
- [Man] How about over-production?
- Over-production is not lethal
but the cells are--
- I think that's far
from just contributing to
robustness, essentially.
- Yeah, that's true.
It is lethal but we don't know
all the functions of that.
- [Man] So my question was:
is part of the coupling
to growth because that
methyl transferase requires
SAMe or tetrahydrofolic acid--
- [Both] SAMe.
- [Man] So is growth
coupled in an intimate way
via methionine levels or
methionine biosynthesis--
- We've never done that, that's
an interesting experiment.
We've not asked that.
And it's interesting, even the SAMe
is cell cycle control and
comes up at the same time
in the cell cycle as a CcrM
but that's a good experiment,
we should do that.
- [Man] What would happen
if you blocked cell division
with cephalexin and you got filaments
but DNA replication continues?
I'm sure you've done that.
- You have very sick cells.
- Sick.
They elong and they die.
- They elong and they die?
- [Man] What would happen, E coli has
rounds of replication in rich media
that initiate before--
- We can't do that in caulobacter
because it's so tightly coordinated.
- [Man] But do you think this
kind of mechanism would work
in an organism like E. coli?
- Well, E. coli has its own way
of regulating the
initiation of replication
which has to do with the
Sec protein that binds--
- All the other site,
all the other gates--
- Yeah, I think that E. coli is gonna
have different kinds of gates.
I think whatever I've told you applies
to the Alphaproteobacteria
and not all bacteria
and bacteria are very clever creatures
and they have designed all kinds
of different regulatory mechanisms.
Is it gonna be a logical progression?
Sure, it's not stochastic events
that make E. coli be E. oli.
They just haven't been
worked out in this way
and what's helped this of course
is we can synchronize these cells easily
and there's very tight control
and this tight control is
not observed in E. coli.
- [David] Are there any more questions?
Thank you--
- Thank you.
- For a wonderful lecture, appreciate it.
(audience applause)
(solemn music)